my name is Stella darest I'm an
assistant professor in the nightstand I
just like to introduce shot Babcock and
I this I did wasn't told that I was
supposed to make decisions which are
basically going to presents opportunity
to diagnosis of prostate cancer using my
speakers not shown this way to do a
little introduction of prostate cancer
in the United States
so the 9h 2018
projections for prostate cancer we
prefer the highest in new cases reported
and 2018 that behind one cancer of
breast cancer cases the top revivalist
is actually counterfeit percent of all
three cases cancer are and so the
prostate cancer 5-year survival is quite
high one two percent however there are
keys to that survival rate versus tumor
size so early detection
you know we've attached to learn when
it's small and had a better cancel three
two one the next is the mobilizing the
usual confinement
will flex we find in the student
prostate gland itself from regional
confinement of years the prostate gland
itself and lymph nodes around o+ anyone
anywhere else is metastasized that I
need for the two drops from
and then third is we have an accurate
assessment of the aggressiveness of the
cancer residents of cancer Metro by
police and school scores basically taken
from biopsies for the look at the cells
and compared the amount of sales that
are on normal cells normal healthy cells
Mellencamp's ourselves and cameras using
schoolwork the way general the concept
of the Gleason score is if it's selling
above our range at one the county
settlement above is considered a
clinically significant or aggressive and
then that leads to treatment if it's
below or the lease is 407 and it's
usually just monitored over time to make
sure that it doesn't get it so currently
prostate cancer diagnosis members versus
the prostate cancer screening using two
methods either a prostate specific
antigen blood cells or a digital rectal
exam if you're going to be having
elevated PSA a or eat already ever in
the haven't even found typical is to go
to a biopsy which is either a blind
biopsy or a transrectal ultrasound
guided biopsy which is in each body
blend labs use was actually a array of
twelve small medium and it's just what
it says it's blind they go mayhem and
hope that they following the area
causing the under Marilyn ease our
elevator feels available friend of the
trust guided biopsy goes in with just
the one deal because it's image dried up
and we'll take samples of them cells and
then from there we have a Gleason score
and determine that steps a doubt down
the other line in biopsy is Madam
President
imaging MRI the keyboard
and that's basically using instead it's
enjoyed abroad recently the trust biopsy
we use the hemorrhaging now this
obviously to be able right machines more
expensive and some facilities may not
having access to the Onaga machine so
very good at all I also took note you
know we do get an elevated PSA level and
one these do biology methods comes back
negative on the level of gives a little
still elevated is recommended of like
okay so let's talk about the screening
methods and my blind and trust biopsy
methods and some limitation trust agents
to the energy test has been shown to be
quite variable
even among two patients I have the same
answer level we did different levels and
on repeated visits the levels may vary
and so is the digital rectal exam they
supposed to be empty review of the
prostate gland which is brutal zone but
even detects anything in the central
zone or the transitional zone and even
in these two areas it's not good at
detecting that an implants in there but
as I mentioned blind biopsy is just one
record that they get the live area
because it's not image guided and so it
named me us or it might be miss the
tumor site which there was more healthy
cells and cancer cells and the video
that I want to point out the enemy
because web sites of literature still
bring it up but it's being phased out in
place of the trust biopsy so implicitly
an image guided by UPS man but even
trying to trust ymz is not a factor as
what we saw go general on the rate of
angle which was the okay so listen to
run the the accurate of the image guided
biopsy services the anymore guided
biopsy and so here in human usually the
radiologist will examine the MRI images
looking for regions of interest so
suspect for regions and then those
readers of interest they will determine
to deliver layman to their what benign
malignant areas will be targets for
biopsy
I mentioned in green accuracy and also
for trust by us in Italy this local
device ground truth or computer image
analysis which we're talking about here
because we're getting ground through
from the biopsy to tell us either leave
the score or simply blame them for of
knowledge however we still see the
possibility of over biopsy just due to
human visual limitations so what is the
resolution that women can work an image
and try to detect differentiate between
attack
sure that it was Malaysia no more
textures of spelling obviously we can go
Alan see that mean pixel relationship
also just the sheer amount of images in
a day or someone might have a book out
fatigue level sets in and also the
experience level of the particular
radiologist that's working with these
images probably the more experienced
America better and that kind of ties in
with there's generally no set standard
for what gives malignant looking image
of what it's benign looking image and so
that kind of ties back into the
experience there's a little computer
computer analysis of the multi paramedic
a long ride this is a literature review
of what's currently being researched and
done and these have basically two goals
so what is the classification of
prostate cancer malignant or benign and
then some are going to determine a
Gleason score from a number of leading
scorer off of the anecdotal always and
people will either accurate targeting of
biopsy size so that's better
differentiation of what is malignant or
what should you go and look at to reduce
over biopsy of areas that aren't or
benign I am simple approaches or news
first is a feature extraction and
classification or too loose on the first
slide is the area on there without the
second engine as part of the people are
using convolutional neural map and then
some studies will go in and actually try
to use the puter
annotation of the region of interest so
the computer will going segment the
image and try to point out what is a
region of interest then analyze is
already known open are very few to
there's most of
that you believe actually use
radiologists imitative of reasons of
interest and then start from there okay
what a movie paramedic him all right
so this consists of four little down
when these from MRI images and I listed
them from the most usable each used in
the context of prostate cancer detection
the first is a t2-weighted image the
lift relies on the water content of
tissues so it's very good at detecting
the spatial differences tissues with
different water contents one of the
problems is that it's not very good at
detecting tumors in the central zone and
transitional zones you saw the yellow
and green home each other because the
water content of healthy tissue when
those zones mimics what a second use is
a diffusion weighted image and that
looks at the diffusion of water
molecules in the tissue and so that
specifically doing that working out cell
types and cell density so if you take a
sample of the tissue in that area if the
self densities are large and the cell
membranes are compromised by being
cancerous they will have less diffusion
bandwidth healthy tissue and from their
inclusion coefficient map is created
from the MRI software of their gene
software and it's the ATC maps of Eros
damage analysis and these will show a
darker spot or the the darker the area
of the lesson fusion fission next time
the line is a dynamic contrast
enhancement image this is much like the
diffusion weighted image but it uses a
contrast is injective that's a little
more expensive if you have to use a
contrast and another element engine so
tamson image analysis police use is more
expect Islamic images I've only seen
them mentioned in one paper out of all
the papers unfit so that's it
so basically the teacher way to be seen
Apple predominantly use of that's what I
will be using the house the two
modalities in this study here's the
picture of the teaching waited on the
right hand left hand side in the day and
have yattawan is indicated by the way
that everyone as you can see it's very
hard it is for leaning zoom
differentiating the region of interest
area from the rest on the prosthetic on
this side is the the ADC map and you
guys can tell on google you can get a
little darker area doctor first color
look we've got video and made the from
the table from actually so these are
nice images and these are from a yep
same patient just a to image modalities
and on the day this one okay so the
project definition so you know I tend
evaluate the feasibility machine
learning that ones which are feature
attraction and classification they're
differentiating the malignant and benign
tumor classification with the exam
ability an algorithm that best reduces
over biopsy and if we really get after a
silikal biopsy so if we were quite
accurate we could skip the Emmanuel
biopsy process and say this is the
computer has done the biopsy and we
moved from treatment the Hmong animal
the image isn't so perfect we have
processed images from England Paige
don't exploit to erode OHS Joe and was
81 page let's break down into 58 minute
Dan and from these we can get under 75
religion and 65 in our images so what
we're saying is we're getting multiple
images per patient because the way MRI
will go in and slice it will take slices
not physical slices put image slices of
the prostate gland for both modalities
of the image so we get more images
multiple images for patient the reasons
of interest have been outlined by
radiologists a lot of it amenities and
you know are high in more guideline
hours it is used to provide the ground
truth so that's telling us that we
verified that these are malignant over
nothing good news is what patients have
been screened and right now within this
data is currently being processed so we
hope we hope to this dataset larger in
the near future the impairments per
person so the in some cases we have
versus settlement
teaching weight advantage is another and
this is an example from table here with
the from the denying patient for both
modalities of a window patient for both
localities I'm ganna pointing out where
we choose an interest or you can see
about these are nobodies bhajans e on
the teaching waiver because this is the
projector it was a little bit
frightening
and then here's the same image outlines
are actually those are the reasons
interest outlined by the radiologist the
allows able to - sometimes them directly
actually cause the when they take the
images and they slice for the
t2-weighted images and then slice for
the future weight of the images they
will get off on the registration but
there's really the heart of the matter
for the algorithm flowchart in the
beginning starting with the TGA of the
medium use the CRO eyes and do the extra
feature extraction from those regions of
interest and now we'll create an entire
text from each of the vector will talk
about the 3d methods that we're going to
use on the next slot and from Dave's we
will do the pension or absorption and
three methods of dimension of judgement
we want to reduce the dimensions so we
can get use just the features that best
predictive classifiers and get rid of
the ones that may cause confusion and
aren't helping our position and that
would be able to say they reduce easier
that room and then the classification
we're gonna use three members and
proposed with the data set we have now a
five fold cross validation for the
training and from the classifiers will
give receiver operating characteristic
curve curve ROC curve and for that we
will judge the metric on how well we're
performing and now we're going to be
doing what they were doing um I'm going
to begin across combinations of these
methods so in all totally imprinted 327
to form combinations so we'll be able to
paralyze for seven different algorithms
to find out richest of us
okay so text feature extractor again
with this one's about leave them in for
an extract artist extra features into
this vector and they're pretty
government we're going to use with any
good pretty [ __ ] cool Paris Angeles
it's very old method of extra feature
extraction they improve and unused in
the law of the lizards or healthy it's
based on the spatial relationship of
pixels in an image so next to each other
or a distance from each other and from
this we can calculate second word
statistics of the image texture this
will be fourteen heroin images that 1973
eater of ways of describing these from a
poet or injury the second will be a
little my hair you have so this is a
very conversational addition simple and
efficient and describing the local
texture feature of an image apply
cultivated and made a neighborhood
pattern so a neighborhood around the
pencil so we can get local features and
then we completing these into a
histogram and see the overall image how
many you know what how many of one
feature does it or a pattern that they
have and calculate mister ground so
distributions that we can see and the
third is a multi-dimensional fractal
analysis so this is basically a
combination of wavelet energy
composition and fractal dimension
calculation and then analyzes to pull
the small and the large and so what it
is is imagine a 3d structure a lot of
people use one Weibull at one frequency
and that may not capture what the best
parts of the image so this uses four
frequencies of labeler to decompose the
image then we learn fractal dimensions
calculations on those and detect which
upper four is the best you can play the
same for wavelets to that particular
decomposition run the practical
dimension again we'll be building the 3d
structure
so we get down to where we're not
getting any difference pressurization
let me stop there and that riddle and
the way the fractal dimensions cut it
down as we look better in school and
then then pieces as we go down okay
protective feature extraction other
descriptors and somebody asked me today
said okay is this texture in the
standard concept though attached to that
you would feel or is this some computer
painting that you guys would come up
technical firmly so don't say that right
I very good description of a tax jury or
attention to strong eyes the service of
a feature and the descriptors saying
what that service of the feature looks
like and so these methods are widely
used you know the search of this time to
describe the features so persons not
home today and that's makes you have
smoothness or the flatness of an image
if you want to put it in in contrast
which is shown here and this is
basically judging the gray level
differences in the image did we have a
very black very why but we now the sub
range of Gray's importantly and this
looks at the correlation between the
pixels and correlations good
you kind of see the correlation how do
they correlate it gives good at looking
at we're headed powder was in a in a
minute but then the local feature
extraction is to grab statistics they're
not good for here or we can kind of see
we've got a lot of local features that
are the same in this image so that we
can go down the in the story and then
the fractal dimensions and that's good
they're both local and global attention
features as well house for often a
finisher okay affectionately with arson
but not I mentioned this we want to do
this we want to weed out the features
that are not very good that they're
taking
classes and get down to a small subset
of that our policy makes a lot easier to
understand and computationally expensive
and the first thing uses inelastic now
and this is basically a regular rifle
direction that captures the Olin can use
the lasso entries of original aggression
lasso regression tends to break it down
if you have that you're the script or
features are much larger than the number
of data points you have
so if you have anyone patience for the
data point but may have a lot more
descriptors from that and so this method
was developed by Trevor has he and
colleagues down in Stanford so if you
ever taken Shannon's of statistical
class that's boy maybe came up with this
with the intent of getting all the
problems of the lasso regression the
next is automate over run English right
to paint the picture with a few words
essentially the neural network that
employs an equal sized input and output
writers and reduced size narrow layers
so the concept here is there equal sized
input and output you put your entire
feature vector on the input type feature
vector on the output and train the Nats
us that the inner layer is an encoded
version and representation of what the
overall feature vector would be and so
smallest inner layer represents your
reduce feature set they can think of it
you're taking this image and mirror it
back and have your input vector features
here and you'll reduce smallest
be percept there at which this encodes
that and then it in the learning process
because it back to match what original
text or feature vector really and then
the third is the minimum redundancy
maximum irrelevance
this is used a lot of the previous work
that we say and it pretty much does
exactly we want to think of what the
kind of setup and so this determines the
feature subset with highest correlation
or predictability to the class at the
same time determine which features are
correlated highest amongst themselves
and so this will if you have ten
features that all predict very well we
don't people town and so when will
reduce something there okay occupation
so the first is work vector machine this
is using a lot of literature as well
with very good results so this is
supervised machine learning method to
find hyperplane maximum separation
between the classes between our two
classes and this kind of readings is
that in the visionaries in a linear
curve without knowing their kernels and
a lot of papers will have noticed that
the classes are not linearly separable
so polynomial polynomial kernel of a
regular basis kernel will be a better
and then random forest so this is a
super binders ensemble learning
algorithms multiple decisions for you
and a classification is based on
majority vote from a decision tree so
then you can uses a bagging method which
is a bootstrap aggregation to build the
trees and take the majority vote
bagging them is good it's through the
high variance low bias
predictors like classification trees
white decision trees it's also included
in the fact that the attempts to be
resistant to overfitting you're wrong
although the presence of no easy data
and the state of may be noisy so they
come in handy and then logistic
regression which is using the linear
combinations of the variables to predict
the problems over the K classes in this
case we have two classes this is tied
right in with the elastic map and it's
in the same song
or package and so these two kind of go
hand-in-hand okay and results analysis
so basically as we mentioned reviews are
we see curves on the classifier for
their kind of a deltoid exam will three
classifiers on the colors and we will
basically take the area under these
curves as our metric I point out the
bottom line which is you know referred
to as a bit coin flip line if you were
if you're kind of are told before that
you might we'll just put the coin those
two 50/50 rich Anil so you really want
your classifiers these curves to be a
better direction like this for maximum
area moving further and definitely have
maximum classification also we want to
add is a year for all of our models
combinations of models that we look at
and get to our seekers from we also want
to look out and identify the top
performing or the top features that
attributed is that model score now in
some cases we attract this back to the
actual features that were extracted
themselves in the case of MOR mor or
lying or something like that now the
auto encoder that encodes the feature so
there was no real way to decode them
back so we would hope to I've seen
several I've seen several papers that
have gone through and I said well okay
there's there's a little autumns we test
them here's their metrics of goodness
that area under the curve and then here
is made the top five top ten features
that contributed to that model school
obviously you have a small sample size
and that's going to be a problem in
training some of our classifiers
especially on the auto encoder since it
is a neural network
you know networks was
potato fluency secondary and so that may
be a problem with our auto encoder to
give analysis between malignant and
benign in patient samples and that
somewhat comes with the territory
obviously if we're looking at a
radiologist pointing out regions of
interest of biopsy they're trying to
advanced do not over biopsy we're trying
to best the safe yes these are malignant
go biopsy and the fact that they give
benign means that they saw something
that looked a maybe with malignant or
they were still denying so that was over
biopsy didn't need to be biopsy so we
tend to get unbalanced take ourselves
and much of the literature has
unbalanced datasets Emma and they do
they're some little boom I'm taking the
dataset and just thrown out malignant
samples of thousands out but then maybe
a data set where we on 81 patients they
get data sets up in the high teens low
twenties so there is an issue that as
far as the small dataset as I mentioned
hoping to get more data through the size
that dataset and then my daily bread 3d
images here we're just looking at they
were just looking at pixel relationships
on 2d plan whereas on 3d playing now we
can look in the y-direction and get more
data that allows us to even add in some
first order statistics such as the shape
and the size of the region of interest
over V now and if you need though this
richer there's some say that 2d and 3d
don't make a difference and some say the
3d is better than 2d and it depends on
what study you're doing in the future
abstraction and classification rail most
papers for prostate cancer and I've even
seen a lung camps paper and
her favorite singer 3-yard pepper and
these are the papers that have compared
them side by side with the same methods
and come up and you guys I have those
and then we need to do to iii-v and then
here's a project timeline but I've
broken down into three sections was kind
of the post data mental analysis where
we are today
here's we get all the software racing
tested for modulus of software very
intensive and then the section on the
actual data and therefore the analysis
and with the results evaluation so I'm
going to get the features extracted by
the first week of September an initial
pipeline tested and running so let's
just choose probably all of the features
one dimension reduction and one
classifier so make sure you go through
all the way through the pipe warning and
then follow up with all the combinations
by the end of October so that's all
across combination for eighty twenty
seven and then give time for the results
analysis and additional methods so we
find that the classification of it for
example that it was not doing well at
all we can hopefully have time to
substitute in mm mm and then rerun the
data on that and it also gives us time
for any additional data that comes in
and then in the post analysis which is
basically the light up the official the
pants in February
[Music]
[Music]
yeah the winter I mean I could shove
that into the white mark yes for example
somebody should packages that might be
downloading you someone have to write it
myself so in in the practice in the
fractal and I also have gotten a
software that will do various labels and
so I can use that for wavelet
decomposition and I could run that
against you know tests and say okay am I
getting this done which I haven't I have
done that I'm using a good for way it
looks on like them usually and then I
really software to do the fractal
dimension calculations which is a box
counting method and I've written that
and I already have that verified so it's
just it's just doing things like that
Oh grabbing me I've got elastic now I'm
test of the value but that's one thing I
want to do is go through and run test
samples through that there's to make
sure it's working before the PNG is from
the MRI images
[Music]
[Music]
yeah one of them going to take now we
may run into problems because we have
house we gon say let's say you have a
patient then you get six slices
obviously you're going to get a very
large slice and a lot of texture
information some of the smaller slices
you get to have poor texture information
a lot of texture information those may
have in the waste of the data set
because even though this is milena
it's hardly differentiated from the
phenomenon and so we may have to cost
some of those small ones that are not
going to first because I want to make
assumptions on the video but that may be
something to try and see if I can first
classification actors some of these are
pretty small on how much pixel
information
yes sectional on the software they're
using yeah I'll try to go through I mean
I have manages the 3d images I showed on
the other slide were purposely builds of
the at different ranges of textures
whether somewhere called machining out
somewhere in LA somewhere local features
to go through and just making sure that
I'm Kara significant differences that
way one photo a man some packages come
with the test images so I can actually
compare line installed incorrectly
well yeah anywhere to talk to Fergus
coldly who's of the benefactor all right
there under the truth yeah and that kind
of gets into the okay multiple people
with different experience levels there
was a study I'd rather 2017 who Stamper
that came up with a computer model and
their computer model did better
predictions and a radiology with two
years of experiments far they performed
worse down evasion fifteen years been so
yes that would have a batch back then
but this is I'm assuming that will be
[Music]
yes I I have the paper I have two colors
together
it's not good